oh [ __ ]
oh man I wasn't ready for that he's the
guy with the camera right really
really
the [ __ ]
oh we saw this earlier
then what but you never picked it up and
you should village records have stored
in the sermonette mass trials many
disgusted I didn't fall cares of rituals
there should be many records fall coral
Valley or the forbidden ratios also
called the Korean sacrifice riddle twins
I used to help seal the gates of hell
and there are two parts the visible
ceremony which occurs periodically and
it if it fails a hidden sermon is to
perform if Alzheimer's failed the gate
to hell with open the dead would pour
out and skies would go dark they they
call this disaster the furnace I guess
that's what happened here because it
fits pretty well the whereabouts of
munakata friends the twin voice is -
yeah I can't say Japanese names it's
Suki and mutsuki are known which is a
little troubling I find our fam if they
are found I find out I can't read either
I might be able to ask them about the
village
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh let's go I'm pumped
no I'm
[Music]
okay so it's in here we put the key no
nope
all the time seriously though that's
pretty [ __ ] up I'll just pretend that
it's not there and let's go here I know
and I have the key so it's fine
you don't have to tell me Oh dolls dolls
hate dolls
No
the [ __ ]
what happened you're a [ __ ] I forgot to
tell you the ritual what is going on
right now mm-hmm
of course we promised for now let's get
out of here
yes uh-huh
yeah I don't even know what to think
about that I get it's taking picture of
dolls pretty [ __ ] creepy dolls
it's that one it's haunted
it looks like the same doll
something shows in the photo yes I know
I love this
let's get out of here
[Music]
here's that you think your Taff huh you
think your tack you think your tap
oh [ __ ] she's gonna come a lie save
station saves it
okay got it you think your top huh
finger tap
don't just oh [ __ ] I knew it pick your
time
pick your time
I don't like this oh man that's so
creepy
reload
oh man what I totally took the photo
yeah let's take a photo of her but maybe
she doesn't like that ha I knew it
ok way she
[Music]
we're not there's just
ah she doesn't work well with that angle
maybe this will work
ah
ha but the flam
where
okay let's go shouldn't this be a fatal
frame where's she going right here
where's she going she's so [ __ ] I'm
right here wait the flame [ __ ] okay
where'd she go
right
where you think you're done oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
but the flam okay that wasn't a photo
frame but whatever
ah I need I need I need I need tiny
okay it's okay
[Music]
all right she where is she
up where
are they shoes oh that's so [ __ ]
creepy
now I'll go for my you
okay we got it I'll save your ass again
I saved your ass every day you think
your time huh how boob slap you huh
look man me boob slapping you huh huh
you're like my what anyway we should
stop that huh twin dolls head they are
old but beautifully decorated they
probably had okay we should bring them
back or something out of them ha a boob
Saipan half and Boop's IPO
it was an awesome sound effect for boob
slaps okay now we can return the heads
there's something I don't know yes the
sound came from the doll stop it seems
Tina starting the head makes the
mechanism start to work
oh crap okay I did a safe snake
my idea was that there's they are in
Paris or something but I always don't
know
crap that needs to be here I don't have
a couple seconds on my hand I think
after we do this not there they are
maybe they stopped after a certain
length of time
yes I will insert them
shut up
oh come on chef ah oh boob Savio if you
say it one more time I freakin boob
don't you sorry
I really shouldn't do that
yes yes lucky for her
I don't give a [ __ ] okay good for you
shut up about the butterfly about of
fives in my stomach okay we got those
ready I can't remove that [ __ ] this
account what
five what am I supposed to do
yes I leave and do it again wait let me
see here yes
[Music]
6/6 to go with the orange colored iris
to the top in case the dolls don't know
we should always I mean I'll draw a
diagram here in dolls position
I need to move up those two needs to be
on
oh okay I got it
sorry about that so the orange ones
needs to be on top because they're the
only ones without a head or something ir
hi